hi my name is Dan Fletcher I'm a
professor of bioengineering and
biophysics at UC Berkeley and my lab
works on the cytoskeleton we're
interested in how forces sculpt cellular
organization and behavior but a little
over a year ago I wasn't doing that I
was taking some time to work at the
White House very different experience
from from working in lab and I went to
washington d.c out of an interest in
understanding why the taxpayers are
paying us to do research how public
policy makers are using the information
that we are generating and what is there
that we can do to improve that that
process and so it turned out to be a
tremendous experience I thoroughly
enjoyed the time there but it's great to
be back and in a research lab part of
the reason i enjoyed it is it exposed me
two very different people and very
different experiences than i have during
my normal career most of us haven't
really been outside of academia if
you've been in academia as a result you
don't really get a chance to understand
some of what motivates different parts
of the country so this was a chance to
get a little bit of our perspective on
that broad set of people so I wanted to
talk about a few of the experiences that
I had in DC but also try and identify a
few thoughts on how to be effective in
communicating research ideas which is a
central role for scientists in
Washington DC so Washington DC is a
whole new world very different from
Berkeley where I live and very different
from most academic environments it's a
very formal place I had to wear a suit
and tie every day I had to go to
meetings on time it was a very unique
experience I always even told to get a
haircut and that was by karl rove and
Matt and I didn't get a haircut but it
taught you
of things about how people organized and
how people decide what policies are
worthwhile there's not an experiment you
can do to decide that policy it comes
from conversations from interactions and
that's why cocktail parties in
Washington DC are so important they're
like our conferences there's no poster
exhibit but there is a chance to
exchange information so what does a
scientist do in Washington DC well my
goal in part was to be a link to
research labs active research labs that
are producing this information that the
taxpayers are paying for and to provide
some insight on how that process works
and hopefully some specific knowledge
that would be useful in policy policy
decisions I came to Washington DC as
part of a program called the White House
Fellows Program and it's a program
that's been around since about nineteen
sixty-five and it brings early career
professionals from a wide variety of
disciplines to Washington DC for an
experience there and my class of fellows
was a group of 14 people and a fantastic
and varied group of people including
doctors and lawyers and business people
and people from the military a fabulous
experience and a wonderful group of
people so about half of my time in
Washington DC was spent working with
this group of people and we met with
over a hundred different speakers over
the course of the time there including
President the Vice President various
cabinet secretaries and other
influential people such as colonists and
activists and so in those meetings we
got a chance to discuss a wide variety
of ish issues and it was very
educational process the other half of my
time was spent at the White House Office
of Science and Technology Policy working
together with the science advisor as
well as a variety of other people in
that office and we worked on issues that
ranged from life sciences to biosecurity
to health technology men each day more
issues would be coming in
or you would be trying to push other
topics forward and many of the decisions
that need to be made were what do we do
next what is the right role for the
government in a particular topic whether
its stem cell research or the
requirement for certain health
information to be made available um one
thing I observed right away was that
Washington DC is a very busy place a
very fast-paced environment there's not
a lot of time for contemplation things
happen very quickly and people work very
hard so have a great deal of respect for
the civil servants who form the core of
the government so in this process that
is so fast-paced what is the role for
science so it was really exciting to see
that everywhere I went and the people I
talked with science is something that is
broadly supported Democrats Republicans
the White House the Congress science is
seen as a real key to addressing
national problems and national
priorities and so that was wonderful to
see what was less clear was how is the
information that we're producing getting
into these environments it's to some
extent through advisory councils to some
extent through news stories but there
weren't direct routes to figure out what
does the future look like and that's
that was surprising to me it was also
surprising and maybe a little
disheartening to realize that science is
not the answer that is science doesn't
address a policy issue completely it
provides a lot of the background
information but at some point someone
has to be a decision-maker someone has
to say this is how we're going to do it
not this way and many times that's a
value judgment that's not a scientific
judgment and as a result science is
playing a role up to a point and after
that it's it's balancing of various
interest and balancing those interests
is the great challenge of any system of
government and getting a perspective on
where science plays a role was was a
very rewarding part of this experience
so this brings me to me
the main point and that is how can we a
scientist be effective in Washington DC
what is our role I think there are five
things that we can do we can do one is
we need to play a role in synthesizing
ideas we are all experts in specific
areas but those specific areas and that
particular topic is only going to be
part of a solution and so if we can play
a role in synthesizing what we do
together what other people do to come up
with solutions that's going to be much
more effective than than just describing
the work that we're doing individually
so being able to synthesize being a
little broad is very important and being
effective in in Washington DC second is
recognizing the diversity of interests
people come to Washington DC with lots
of different polls on them and
understanding who's in favor of an idea
who's against an idea is a critical part
of moving a topic forward third and
something I didn't realize until a few
months into this program was that famous
people are just people even if you're
sitting in the Oval Office or having
lunch with colon Powell these are these
are people they've done amazing things
but they benefit from the same sort of
hard questions the same sort of critical
assessment that we do in improving
ourselves in our work and so I think
that's an important thing to remember
when you're interacting with government
officials is they adhere to the same
rules of logic that we do fourth is come
with solutions not just with problems
the most effective way to make progress
in Washington DC is to have a solution
and if you simply point out a problem
with the way funding is done or the lack
of funding in a particular area that's
not a solution there are lots of
problems the government deals with it's
much more exciting and much more
productive to come with a solution how
to move forward on that topic and lastly
maybe most importantly is that we as
scientists have a perspective on where
our fields are going and that's the
vision we need to share with
the policymakers in Washington DC we
have ideas we have a perspective that
they aren't going to have the time or
the ability to to have and we need to
come up with ways of sharing that
perspective a quote i like that relates
to this is one piece of advice given to
wayne gretzky the the ice hockey player
when he was told to not skate to where
the puck is but skate to where the puck
is going to be i think that's the big
challenge in government devising
policies that are going to be
appropriate for where the world's going
to be in then 10 20 years and we're the
ones who have an idea where science is
going to be in that amount of time so we
need to play a role in conveying that
idea so it was a wonderful experience to
be in DC but I'm wonderfully happy to be
back in berkeley back in lab and
enjoying the west coast thank you
you